[Music]
straight ahead on Long crime daily my
testimony today
is the fact that Megan killed her kids
and killed herself okay a man accused of
murdering his family is cross-examined
by the prosecution as the only defense
witness in the case and Miss patino
versus laundry a judge orders a jury
trial in the assorted family Lawson plus
the accused Brooklyn Subway shooter is
arraigned in federal court the latest
details out of New York City but first
an inside look into the lives of Johnny
Depp and Amber Heard with misheard he
was triggered and
um they engaged in what I saw as Mutual
abuse she was spitting in my face and
it's telling me how dare I asked for the
salary I was asking for the latest
developments in the multi-million dollar
defamation trial lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and crime daily I'm your host Brian
buckmeyer we're getting a behind the
scenes look at Johnny Depp and Amber
heard's relationship from some of the
people closest to them law and crimes
Angela Levy tells us about the couple's
drug use and how her treats people in
her life
jurors watched videotape depositions
from Amber heard's former personal
assistant and the couple's marriage
counselor
would you ever see any types of injuries
on her yeah
do you ever see any cuts
no
did you see bruises no how about Miss
heard having black eyes never Kate James
testified she worked for Amber Heard for
nearly three years from 2012 to 2015.
she described herd as verbally abusive
at times and how she treated her family
her four sister was treated like the dog
that you kick basically did her mother
tell you she was terrified of her
personally told me
James said her drank red wine and used
mushrooms cocaine and ecstasy she said
she never saw damage to death in herd's
apartment and that herd only wore makeup
when she was going to an event marriage
counselor Dr Laurel Anderson described
Depp and herd's mutually abusive
relationship Mr Depp told you Amber gave
as good as she got correct correct did
you ask what Mr dutt meant by Gabe as
good as she got I was pretty aware of
what he meant I agreed what did you
understand Mr defamine she initiated
fights she started violence she Rose to
the challenge if he started first
Anderson said Deb tried to de-escalate
fights more than heard and that heard
admitted to hitting Depp but she said
heard showed her bruising on her face
and she talked about the differences in
the couple during therapy sessions Ms
heard had a jackhammer style of talking
she was very amped up he had trouble
talking at a similar Pace he was cut off
a lot he couldn't keep up with her rapid
fire way of conversation and so he was
really overwhelmed court is only in
session Monday through Thursday so
testimony will resume in the Johnny Depp
Amber Heard defamation trial on Monday
for Law and crime daily I'm Anjanette
Levy
thanks Anjanette after two witnesses
testified for a while Thursday morning
something shocking happened in the
courtroom when the third witness of the
day and Johnny Depp's good friend is
asked to leave mid-testimony
thank you
have you been watching the trial this
past week
I've seen clips of it online yeah you've
been watching so you have seen parts of
this trial
yeah okay and witness testimonies
yes you've seen him thanks all right
your excuse me you can have your excuse
okay thank you
I will I will instruct the jury they'll
have to strike the testimony
joining us today is legal analyst Kirk
nurmi and co-host Terry Austin Kirk we
kind of saw it a little there but Kate
James was the former professional
assistant for Amber Heard but she
testified in favor of Johnny Depp what
stood out to you about her testimony
ultimately the fact that she was Amber
heard's former personal assistant stands
out because you wouldn't expect a person
like that to be speaking out against
their old boss unless of course the jury
could classify her as a better
ex-employee but that factor is going to
be huge because will the jury take her
as a bitter old employee or someone who
has a great deal of insight not only to
Amber Heard but into the relationship in
general and her belief her assertion
that she not saw no signs of domestic
violence during the relationship yeah
more points that they think Johnny
Depp's lawyers are trying to get in
there about seeing actual abuse or what
her's relationship was with other people
Terry a witness was excused and we kind
of saw a bit of that there can you
explain why and do you think that will
impact the case
well that witness Was Dina deuter's and
she was actually the wife of an
individual named Stephen who worked for
Johnny Depp she traveled a lot with him
she was a close friend of Johnny's and
she was very kind very demure and what
she described was a relationship where
Johnny basically was the nice one and in
fact Amber was not she was excused
because at some point in the testimony
and it was a point where she started to
talk about who certain people were and
the individual was Debbie Lloyd who is
related to the medical in any event
as that happened Council hopped up
objected and the judge basically then
asked have you seen any I'm not sure how
they knew she had seen some testimony
but she said truthfully yes she had
counsel for death actually wanted to ask
a question the judge didn't know she's
excused she saw some that's it and she
instructed the jury to disregard it it's
going to hurt the case that's a pretty
common rule I'm wondering why no one's
lawyers told their Witnesses not to
watch the trial but of course you keep
watching Law and crime uh daily where
you get the best updates on these cases
thank you both still had on lawn crime
daily what could be revealed when the
families of Gabby Patito and Brian
laundry meet in court but first Subway
shooter Frank James is arraigned in
federal court what charger he now faces
and how long he could spend Behind Bars
foreign
[Music]
welcome back the suspect in this week's
Brooklyn Subway shooting is arraigned in
federal court 62 year old Frank James
was arrested on Wednesday after a
city-wide Manhunt for the suspect James
now faces federal charges of terrorism a
violent attack in a mass transit system
and crossing state lines authorities say
he opened fire in a subway station
Tuesday morning after dropping a smoke
bomb 10 people both on the subway
platform and in a train car were hit by
bullets several others were also injured
New York officials confirmed none of the
injuries were life-threatening right now
investigators are still working to
determine a motive for the attack on
Wednesday James called New York Crime
Stoppers to turn himself in New York
bystanders reported seeing him in
Manhattan's East Village helping police
find James he was then taken into
custody if James was convicted he could
spend the rest of his life Behind Bars
foreign
like I said the police are still trying
to find a motive we've heard that Frank
James had a number of YouTube videos
where he makes rants against homeless
people and even white people in general
could we see hate crime charges added to
this case
you know Brian that's entirely possible
I've seen those videos but I don't know
if it's enough to make this a hate crime
for hate crimes they're not easy to
prove you have to make sure that that
crime is motivated by hate based on a
protect a category like someone's
perceived race religion or sexual
orientation and here you have to look at
his actions his words and his
affiliations so we could see that maybe
but I think his actions don't really
support that the way he was firing at
individuals it was indiscriminate it did
not look as though he was trying to
Target anyone in particular and so I'm
not really sure they're going to be able
to prove that there was a motive and
that that motive was based on hate maybe
there's some other motive or maybe
Insanity I don't know yeah Kirk I'm kind
of looking this now from the defense
standpoint is there a possible insanity
or some kind of mental health defense to
be made here
I think that's the only possible defense
right when we see the video we see an
action on tape but we know he has a
mental health history we assume he does
based on the YouTube videos that Terry
just mentioned so I think when his
Federal public defender is assigned one
of the first things they're going to do
is they're going to begin exploring that
mental health history they're going to
look at his background they're going to
be asking questions about it they're
going to be looking for records medical
records school records all those things
that build up that potential Insanity
defense if they go to trial because that
seems to be the only possible Avenue of
Defense to these charges and potential
State charges down the road as well
absolutely we'll see how those charges
develop we know that there's not a lot
of video from the subway station but
there are a lot of bystanders who took
video so that's probably what's going to
be piecing this case together
and in Michigan a violent climax to a
traffic stop foot chase and a physical
fight over a taser gun ends with an
officer shooting a man in the back of
the head the whole incident caught on
body camera footage it happened on a
residential street on April 4th video
footage shows officers pulling over
Patrick leoya a 26 year old Congolese
Refugee in the video Loyola gets out of
the car as the officer walks up to him
asking him to get back into the car the
officer asked for his driver's license
stating the license plate on the car
didn't belong to the vehicle Loyola
starts to run off with the officer
following close behind he tackles him to
the ground and the two fight in front of
several neighboring houses the officer
shoes Leona while he's lying face down
the officer on top of him and the two
struggle over a shotgun the footage of
the altercation was released on
Wednesday after protests in the city
called for Justice as a disclaimer the
video may be disturbing to some
foreign
get it for me
the plate does not belong on this car
no no no stop stop put your hands right
dude he's got one running
a taser
that's taser everyone
the officer's name will not be released
unless criminal charges are filed
against him he's on paid leave pending
an investigation
coming up on lawn crime daily a family
found slain just miles from Disney World
here at testimony for the man accused of
the murders plus full of dream trial
reveal new details in a complicated
relationship of Gabby Patito and Brian
laundry here are extra analysis next
[Music]
foreign
Landry are headed to court as a Florida
judge sets a date for a jury trial this
week a jury trial was scheduled for
August 2023. this comes as the family of
Gabby Patito files a lawsuit against
Chris and Roberta laundry the parents of
buying laundry the potato family claims
laundry's parents knew their daughter
was murdered and were working to help
Brian laundry leave the country before
he went missing Gabby Patito made a
national headlines last fall after she
was reported missing in early September
her family told officials she had been
on a cross-country road trip with her
fiance Ryan laundry patito's body was
later found in Grand Teton National Park
her cause of death was ruled to be a
strangulation after a weeks-long Manhunt
laundries remains were discovered in a
Florida Reserve authorities determined
he died by Suicide along with his
remains investigators found a written
confession where laundry admitted to
killing potato a according to court
documents patito's parents are now
seeking more than thirty thousand
dollars in Damages from the laundry
family
Terry you've reviewed the complaint in
this case how difficult do you think it
will be for the lawsuit against the
parents of Brian laundry
you know I have looked at this civil
complaint multiple times it's only six
pages long they do request this thirty
thousand but they don't say how they
came up with that calculation so that's
unclear they do a very detailed outline
of the event saying that on July 2nd in
2021 basically they went on this
vacation this road trip and that you
know Gabby never came back obviously but
what they're saying is that Brian told
his parents that he had murdered Gabby
and they did this and subsequent to when
they did that they made an announcement
saying we really hope and pray that he
comes back and she's reunited the only
cause of action that could be included
there is intentional infliction of
emotional distress and you have to have
extreme distress which we have here it
has to be intentional I don't know was
that intentional and it also has to make
sure that uh the case basically the
Behavior was outrageous was it
outrageous I don't know but that would
be the cause of action they don't even
use those words in the complaint though
yeah Kirk tell me if I'm wrong but I see
this case kind of boiling down into to a
few issues maybe Omission or
affirmatively acting if the laundry
family actively hit Brian I get that
that that's a claim right there but if
they simply just kept quiet does that
create criminal or civil liability
yeah and that is I think the Crux of
this case Brian and ultimately we're
talking about to be is to have that
action it has to be criminal action
right aiding and abetting hiding a
fugitive things of that nature in order
for that kind of act that extreme and
outrageous conduct does the failure to
do so does the failure to report rise to
the level of that extreme and outrageous
conduct that Terry pointed out is
necessary for this kind of claim and
that's going to be the Crux of the case
and keep in mind now the laundry parents
haven't been charged there's nothing
that shows that they have conducted
themselves in a criminal manner
the petite the Potato Famine is going to
have to show that in order to Prevail in
this case all right we'll see how
they'll do that thank you both for those
updates an update on a story we first
brought you out of Wisconsin the Green
Bay woman accused of murdering her lover
and dismembering his body is found
competent to stand trial
but there's still another trial delay 24
year old Taylor should business appeared
virtually in court on Wednesday where
Judge Thomas Walsh noted a competency
evaluation found her fit to stand trout
should businesses competency comes into
question based on the very nature of the
crime She's accused of murdering her
lover 24 year old Shane thyrion in
February of this year after that she
dismembered his body according to court
documents therion's mother found his
severed head in a bucket at the bottom
of her staircase at Wednesday's court
hearing sure business his defense pushed
back on the first competency evaluation
saying she has been struggling with
mental health issues for years now
foreign
mental health treatment since the
seventh grade
she's been psychiatric we hospitalized
multiple times
she's been diagnosed with bipolar and
psychotic this may have been one of the
better days however I'm very surprised
at the results
so I was like
Court to say
don't believe the first one you picked
pick somebody up and I'm not sure I'm
I'm there yet further
questions arise
that there should be a would be
evaluation done
I'm not going to order somebody else to
do another one
that this court selects
judge Walsh okay to another competency
evaluation but this time it's going to
be on the defense's dime another
competency hearing is scheduled for next
month
when we come back Anthony Toth takes the
stand in his own defense but how did the
father accuse of a quadruple murder hold
up under cross-examination got to head
on Long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily
switching now to Florida where man
accused the murder it takes a stand as
the lone witness in his defense and
tells the jury he didn't kill his family
Anthony toad is charged with four
accounts of murder and one count of
animal cruelty for allegedly killing his
wife Megan children Alexander Tyler and
Zoe and the family dog Breezy in their
home near Disney World back in December
of 2019. authorities say the former
physical therapist had lived alongside
their bodies for weeks autopsy results
revealed stab wounds and showed toxic
amounts of Benadryl in their systems on
direct examination the 46 year old
blamed his wife for the deaths of their
children telling jurors he came home to
find them dead in their rooms and watch
his wife kill herself in front of him
but that's a different story from the
one he told police in an interrogate
Asian video shown in court Tuesday tote
testified that he tried to kill himself
several times his testimony stretched
into the afternoon on Wednesday with
cross-examination from assistant State
Attorney Danielle Pennell she focused on
Toad's changing story
that
told detectives that you went into Zoe's
room
you've gathered the courage and you
rolled over on top of your daughter
until
isn't that what you told law enforcement
is this a yes or no question did you
want the answer yes or no question that
is what the video yes showed you and
your testimony here today
is that Megan did it
did it Megan
killed Sophie and you told law
enforcement on multiple occasions that
you went into Alex room and you stabbed
Alec and you suffocated out isn't that
correct that's partially correct and
isn't it true that you also told law
enforcement that Megan took part in The
Killing that's what the video showed
that's correct and then in fact Megan
held Alex legs down why you suffocated
out
that's what the video showed that's
correct and your testimony today is that
that is not true my testimony today
is the fact that Megan killed their kids
and killed herself okay
Kirk showing inconsistencies in the
defendant's story is a strong move by
the prosecution how do you think toad
handled himself there
not well at all I mean he didn't have
any real defense to put forward this is
a client in my opinion her defendant in
my opinion that just wanted to exercise
the Sixth Amendment right it was this
kind of Hail Mary he's hoping that his
arrogance or somehow he could convince
the jury and I don't think it's going to
hold up but of course the verdict will
tell us ultimately whether he helped
himself or not yeah now I think Chris
kind of leading into it there but I'll
ask you now that we've heard Toad's
testimony and before we get a verdict do
you think he did himself any favors by
taking the stand
Brian I agree with Kirk 100 he was
arrogant he did not do himself any
favors but I think they had to put him
on the stand and the reason is this he
had to explain his story the evidence is
weighted against him and he has that
confession so no one else is going to be
able to explain away the confession now
whether the jury believes it or not
that's a whole nother story but he had
to say why he made the convection and
his testimony was that he was trying to
protect his wife and you know he also
wanted to say that he had these
religious beliefs that the wife had and
that because of those religious beliefs
that is why she wanted to do this she
thought the world was coming to an end
so he was trying to explain the
rationale behind it so for those reasons
one the confession to explaining the
rationale that is why I think he had to
testify but he did a terrible job all
right well we'll see what the jury
thinks about this thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on lawn
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]